(audience clapping and cheering)
- Stunning.
- Thank you.
- Like my goodness...
- You're stunning.
- You came out like, and
you look like Christmas.
(laughter)
It was like, it was really good.
Are you in the holiday spirit?
Are y'all decorating everything?
- I am.
I'm, I'm gonna do my or I, you know,
I grew up not celebrating Christmas
so now with my son, I
overly celebrate Christmas.
- I grew up with no money.
So now I overdo it with my kids.
Yeah, me too, I go crazy.
- I do ornaments, I collect ornaments
for the tree and I try to collect
them wherever I go on tour.
- Yeah.
- And then I kind of talk about them
with my son and sometimes he was
with me when we got them
and sometimes he wasn't.
And...
- Does he like decorating?
My son loves decorating.
- He loves decorating it, yeah.
He's getting a little too
old and cool for it now.
But I make him 'cause I
really want him to remember.
- Yeah.
- You know what, these sort of...
- Forced family fun, so good.
- Yeah, and also he's got these, like,
he used to be into dinosaurs.
I don't know what your kid, yeah.
- [Kelly] Oh he loves dinosaurs...
- He's now basketball, but for three years
he was gonna be a paleontologist and,
or I thought he was going to be.
- I love it.
- And yeah, and so I had a dinosaur,
a T-Rex ornament that went
on, don't be mad at me,
but it went on the top as the star
instead it was a T-Rex.
- [Kelly] Why mad at you?
- I dunno 'cause some people probably
want something more religious up there...
- Well then they can put
whatever they want on their tree.
(laughter)
- You want a damn dinosaur on your tree,
you can put a dinosaur on
your tree, it's all right.
Doesn't mean anything other
than we like dinosaurs.
Yeah, that's all.
Well speaking of your son and basketball,
it looks like he's got
you coaching him now.
So let's see how this looks.
- [Idina] Oh god.
Yes!
Did you see my alley-oop?
- [Kelly] Look at that
assist, that was amazing.
(audience clapping and cheering)
- Did you hear, though, did
you hear I placed that Kelly?
'Cause you know, 'cause you're a singer
so it was like, "Yes!"
That's really good, she knows.
So I'm not hurting my voice.
- Yeah.
- I like, I can do my, my very, my joy is
is like up there in the range.
- See and people don't
realize that like that's
I can't actually listen to my voice
my speaking voice like anything
'cause I sound nasally to me because...
- You do, you don't sound nasally...
- Well it's easier, it's
easier on my vocal chords
and we sing so often, we work so much.
It's easier when you're coming up and it's
a little nasal and it's a little higher.
- Yeah.
- So it's probably annoying
to y'all, but we don't care.
- But also if I'm ever in the car and
there's like somebody stops short and
I'm worried or something, I'll be like,
"Watch out!", you know?
(laughter)
Or if I'm on a rollercoaster.
- Oh my gosh.
If I'm on a roller coaster I go like,
"Ah, hands off!"
- This is so scary.
- I even did it, you're
gonna think I'm weird,
but when I was in labor I was
like, "The babies coming!"
(laughter)
Cause God knows if I
had a concert to go to,
I didn't wanna hurt my
vocal chord, you know?
- Oh my God, if you would've
just screamed out slash
saying, "Let it go" in that moment,
you would've made a lot of people's lives.
That would've been, that would've made
a lot of people's moments in life.
(audience clapping)
(laughter)
- All right, that's something...
- [Idina] You get it right?
- I do, but now I wanna ride
roller coasters with you.
(laughter)
'Cause I just...
- Hands up!
It's just like, "Into the unknown!"
(laughter)
Maybe just...
- While they're going, I
can't stop picturing it.
- I'm crowning!
- Oh my God, I love you so much.
Oh my God, wait, was your son impressed
by the fact that there was an entire,
'cause I'm impressed, there
was an entire category
on Jeopardy and I wanna
get the title right.
It was recently called "Idina
Menzel Acts and Sings",
that's incredible.
- I...
- You were, there was an entire category.
- I guess that's a big
thing, I will confess.
Don't be mad at me, Jeopardy,
I've never watched the show.
- Oh my god.
- I had so many people text...
- That could have been
one of the things...
- I didn't know anyone watched it anymore.
- For $500, what show has she never seen?
- Yeah.
- Would've been Jeopardy.
- It's, it was amazing, it was like
the best press I've ever gotten.
- Sometimes I think the best I've ever
had I've heard is I was like one of the
things on Jeopardy, but
like not a category.
- Really, oh I'm sorry.
- I was like, yeah.
(making air horn sounds with mouth)
Don't be sorry, wave that flag.
I'm amazing.
I'm amazing!
Just keep waving it.
(laughter)
Do you wanna try a couple now I wanna see
if you'll get 'em right.
- Yeah, cause I don't even
remember what they asked me.
(laughter)
- Okay, okay, well I'm gonna, here we go.
- [Idina] Okay.
- Here's "Idina Menzel
Acts and Sings" for $1,000.
You, Idina got to walk like an Egyptian
on Broadway in this Elton
John slash Tim Rice musical.
(ding)
- What do you say, wait, how do you do it?
Who's, how do you doing the question?
- [Audience] What is.
- Oh, what is Aida.
(celebratory music)
- Oh yes, you're right, you're right.
Hey, here's the thing.
I apparently don't watch either,
cause I didn't know that.
(laughter)
I was like...
- You couldn't even help me at all.
- [Kelly] What is, you're
right, you're right.
- Okay.
- Okay, here is Idina Menzel for $800.
In 1996, you made your
Broadway debut In Rent.
(making air horn sounds with mouth)
- [Idina] Thank you.
- [Kelly] Your character, a performance
artist named Maureen, was based on
Musetta in this Puccini opera.
(ding)
- Oh, what is Rent?
(buzzer)
- [Kelly] Rent?
- Did they say rent?
- [Kelly] Wait, no, no, no.
- Oh, oh, La Boheme, what is La Boheme?
- Yeah, yeah cause it was your character,
oh you, she failed!
(clapping)
(laughter)
(audience clapping and cheering)
- I wasn't paying attention.
- [Kelly] No, I gotta be honest with you
the way I asked that
question was so not okay.
- I just thought, yeah.
- Yeah, no, I was lost in the question.
I don't even know if they'll do a recap
but I was literally
like, while I was asking.
But yes, it's, I didn't
actually know that.
- You didn't?
- No.
- Yeah, original cast on 1995, '96.
- No, I knew you, I didn't
know that the character was...
- Oh, based on La Boheme.
- Yeah, no, I knew you, I
just didn't, yeah, know that.
- Yeah the whole, the whole
show is based on La Boheme.
- I never got that as a teenager like,
in high school when was shown to me.
Anyway, let's try, we're
learning so much today.
(laughter)
Let's try one more.
This Soprano singer is Idina Menzel's
favorite talk show host of all time.
(ding)
I don't, so weird...
- What is Kelly Clarkson!
(audience clapping and cheering)
- I mean, it wasn't a, it
wasn't a real Jeopardy question.
- [Idina] Was that the question?
- It wasn't a real Jeopardy question...
- Oh I wasn't sure I'd remember
I was like that was the question.
(laughter)
(audience clapping and cheering)
- So your new documentary is called
"Which Way to the Stage",
so what's it about?
- I was on, I was gonna
go on tour and I found
out I was playing Madison Square Garden
and at the end of like 16, 17 shows
and growing up in Long
Island that was like
the place to play in New York.
And I always wanted to play there.
And so I thought, I just
wanna document it, you know?
And just because I like to take
in these moments and not
take them for granted.
- We forget them sometimes too.
- Yeah
- Yeah.
- So I documented it then I
had all this great footage.
So then I made a documentary
because I thought it
was gonna be like a Road to
the Garden kind of story.
But it ended up being like a mom
going crazy kind of story...
- Which is way more exciting to watch.
- Well it's just like career, working mom,
trying to be, trying to get back and forth
for trick or treating
and basketball games.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Doing IVF at the time, which I'm not,
you know, I was late in the game.
I have my beautiful little
son, but in my forties I tried
for my, my husband and well
for me, I tried for both of us.
It didn't, can I say it again?
- No, no, you're good, you're good.
- Okay.
- That's a lot of people.
- I don't want the audience to
feel bad for me, it didn't work out.
But I tried hard and I was doing it
the morning of Madison Square Garden.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- I had to go to the doctor and check
my hormones and do all this stuff.
And so the documentary
ended up being much more,
less about a girl trying to
have a great rock concert
at MSG and more about just trying to like,
live my life, and be a good...
- You know what though?
That's the real story.
- Yeah, that ended up
being the real story.
- No, but that is the real story like,
cause people only see the
smoke and mirrors of it.
That's what's so great about you
letting people peek behind the curtain.
I think that's super
important that they know
you're more than just the
product of what they see,
you know what I'm saying?
Like there's more to that, I
think everybody loves that.
- But one of the beautiful
moments in it that I really
love is when my son
would be with me on tour
which can be just as
tiring as trying to go
back and forth because then it's like,
how many children's museums can I see
all over the country on
my day off, you know?
- Yeah, and they're like,
"Why don't you wake up?"
And I'm like, "Oh, because
I go on stage in like,
nine hours and I just need
to like not talk for..."
- I know, and you also
feel guilty about that.
- Yeah.
- But this is when he started playing
basketball and he's this, you know,
he keeps like swearing off the
performing gene in him.
But what he would do is when
we were doing sound check
with the lights and the band
is rocking and he would come
out with the drummer, he'd do his handles
to the beat with the drummer.
- Oh, I love that.
- And like, enjoy the lights coming on and
they work off each other like jazz.
But like, you know...
- [Kelly] That's cool.
- And so there's a, there's some scene
like that that I think
is really beautiful.
You see a silhouette
like this and I'm singing
in the front, the
drummer's doing his thing
and then he walks over and he just puts
his head on me while I'm like trying
to sing and give them sound...
- Yeah.
- Yeah so...
- It's always cool, like it's important,
I think, for our kids to see how,
you know, how hard we work.
- I think especially little boys to see
like their moms, you know, being powerful
and choosing to do what
they love as a passion
and that's not a bad thing, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So I hope he picks a
really good woman one day.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Or man, whatever.
- Yeah.
- But like...
- Yeah whatever he...
- I have a feeling it's a woman,
but I don't know and I don't care.
- Okay, so do you, have
you ever felt like you've
ever been pigeonholed musically?
Because people kind of,
they get one sound from you
and then they expect That I think
really happens to a lot of us.
- I do, like, I can't
break the, no matter how
many songs I do, I played Led
Zeppelin on my tour, you know?
I have this whole side
to me, but people mostly
think that I just come
from musical theater
and no matter how hard
I try, that thing on,
like, Spotify that says, "If you like this
you will also like...",
and it's like Liberace or
like something...
- Which is rad.
- You know, that's cool.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But no, I just, and
it doesn't matter how...
(laughter)
I could sing a duet with
you and it would still
say, you know, something from Oklahoma,
you know what I mean?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So it's just really hard to get people
to see you in in these other ways...
- You have such a huge
voice though, that, like,
it totally makes sense with, like,
the rock and roll vibe.
- [Idina] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- It's just my, I'm gonna
head bang when, like,
as I'm getting older, I
feel like it gets harder
and harder to convince
people that I can do this.
Especially if it hurts my neck.
- See, I think it's, I think
it's easier the older I get.
I feel like because I
just, not that I like...
- You don't care?
- Cared so much when I was younger,
it's just that like I
felt like we're forced to,
like, people put on what
you're supposed to be doing
and it's like, "Okay,
well I'm not trying to,
like, ruffle anyone's
feathers" but then it's like,
"No I like a lot of different things."
Like I wonder whatever...
- Yeah like country, you
did that album when you
were in the black and you
did more rock and roll
and you did the pop...
- I like a lot of stuff.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I think a lot of singers...
- And you trained from opera at first.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, so it's...
- It is how people present,
how you're presented
to the public though, and the first thing,
it's hard to get outta that.
- Yeah, it's really hard to get out of it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh well, I think you're awesome.
- Thank you, I think you're awesome.
(audience clapping and cheering)
- Time for another break.
Everybody watch Idina Menzel, Which Way
to the Stage, streaming on
Disney+ starting December 9th.
And we should mention that Idina also has
a kid's book and it's out right now.
It's cool...
- I left one for you signed
by my sister and myself.
- I love it.
I know, it's called Loud Mouse.
So check out, check that out
wherever you get your books.
- [Idina] Good Christmas gift,
did you just say that already?
- No, but I should've.
- Oh.
(laughter)
- Yeah, you should now
host, I'm telling you,
if I can do it, you can.
- I have mommy brain, oh my God.
- [Kelly] No, me too, me too.